حيث اثرت وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه
باستشهاد شاب فلسطيني برصاصه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على مدخل النبي يونس
في بلده حلحول شمال الخليل من شاهدتها
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان الجيش
الاسرائيليه اطلق النار على فلسطينيا
اثناء محاولتها اطلاقا نيران باتجاه قوه
عسكريه في المنطقه
من القدس
هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه تقول ان الشاب فتح النار
على القوه العسكريه
فاطلقت النار عليه
وردته قتيلا
ما الشواهد التي قدمها الاسرائيليون على
ان الشابه بالفعل اطلق النار على هذه
القوه العسكريه
هذا هو الادعاء الاسرائيلي في البيانات
التي بدات تر اتباع عن في الدقائق الاخيره
وهي تشير الى ان الشاب الفلسطيني وصل الى
احد المداخل مداخل بلده حلحول الواقعه الى
الشمال من مدينه الخليل وفتح النيران
باتجاه القوه العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي
وجدت في المكان وهي كانت تقوم بعمليه
تفتيش للسيارات الداخله الى بلده حنقول
مما استدعى جنود جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى اطلاق النار
والشهود العيان الفلسطينيين في المنطقه
يتحدثون عن ان الشاب قد استشهد وان كانت
هنالك لا توجد ايه معلومات رسميه فلسطينيه
مؤكده حول استشهاده لكن هنالك تاكيد على
ان القوه العسكريه الاسرائيليه همم فتحت
نيراني اسلحتها الرشاشه باتجاه واصابته
وشه يعني الفلسطينيين الذين وجدوا في
المكان يقولون بان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منعت طواقم وفرق الاسعاف
الفلسطينيه من الوصول الى الشاب الفلسطيني
وتقديم العلاج له بعض المصادر الاسرائيليه
تتحدث على انه هنالك اشتباه لدى قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بان منفذ عمليه اطلاق
النار على هذا الموقع العسكري الاسرائيلي
هو نفسه الشاب الذي قام باطلاق النار
باتجاه حافله للمستوطنين قبل يوم دون
وقوعي اصابات وهذه العمليه التي استهدفت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على مدخلي اا
بلده حلحول هذا الصباح تاتي بعد دقائق
معدوده فقط من بلاغات عن استهداف حافله
للمستوطنين في منطقه الخليل ليست هنالك
ليس هنالك كما يؤكد وجود ارتباط بين
عمليات عمليتي اطلاق النار هاتين لكن
العمليه التي [__] الجنود قرب حلحول جاءت
بعد دقائق معدوده من بلاغات من احد سائقي
حافلات المستوطنات عن استهداف حافلته
بوابل من اطلاق النار او ربما انه سمع
اطلاق نار في المنطقه التي كان يسير فيها
قرب جنوب الخليل الحافله كانت خاليه ولم
يبلغ عن وقوع اصابات اطلاقا لكن من الواضح
بان منطقه الخليل بات تشهد في الايام
القليله الماضيه همم سلسله من عمليات
اطلاق النار التي تستهدف مواقع عسكريه
قوات عسكريه مسيره في بعض المناطق وايضا
الحافلات الاسرائيليه التابعه لمستوطنات
الضفه الغربيه المحتله وكانه مدينه الخليل
ومنطقه الخليل بدات تدخل على خط المواجهه
مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حيث ان هذه
المواجهه اقتصرت على الاقل في الشهور
الاخيره او تركز في مجملها في منطقتي اا
جنين همم نابلس لكن بدانا نرى ان الخليل
همم بدات تدخل على خط هذه المواجهه في
الايام الاخيره مع سلسله متتاليه من
العمليات التي كانت تستهدف قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باطلاق نار من اسلحه رشاشه
واستهدافه هذه الحافلات وهذه العمليه
الاولى عمليه التي تستهدف قوه عسكريه
اسرائيليه منذ تولي هيرتيها ليفي همم
موقعه جديد كرئيس لهيئه الاركان العامه
للجيش الاسرائيلي ولا يبدو انها ليفي في
هذه المرحله المتقدمه من عمري ولايته سوف
يغير منها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
التعاطي مع الوضع الامني المتصاعد
والمتوسف في الضفه الغربيه المحتله منذ
الربيع الماضي بمعنى انه سوف يستمر في
النهج الذي وضعه الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في عمليه كاس الامواج في
الربيعه الماضي هذا العمليه التي تستهدف
الى محاصره العمليات في المناطق
الفلسطينيه في قلب المدن
فلسطينيه والحقوني دون تتحرجها الى داخل
المدن الاسرائيليه والى قلبي المدن
الاسرائيليه كما حصل في الربيع الماضي
والاستمرار في عمليات التنشيط الواسعه
وعمليات الدهن والاعتقال اليوميه التي
تطال من تسميهم اسرائيل بالارهابيين
والناشطين في الجماعه المجموعات المسلحه
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله من القدس مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرم شكرا جزيلا لك